Chicago officials hope to win a bid for
Amazon's second headquarters which might
launch them into the top tier of tech-friendly cities. So given that, why on
earth would Chicago's mayor propose a
tax on startups like Lyft and Uber? It
seems sort of anti-tech. I mean, I get the
basic reason: It's a way of raising
revenue for the city's public transit
system. It's becoming a vicious cycle:
public transit problems boost Uber and
Lyft, to the detriment of public transit.
But taxing successful startups to prop
up failing transit systems isn't what's
best for tech or what's best for
consumers. Indeed, some other cities are
already finding value in cutting public
transit and instead subsidizing
ride-sharing. A better approach would be
to embrace new innovations at all
transit sectors. As Uber responded after
the tax was proposed,
"When safe and affordable rides are
available across every neighborhood –
whether by bus train or ride share –
Chicagoans can get to their jobs or
family obligations without having to own
a car."
Do you think government regulations are too tough on tech? Let us know in your comments. Also, let us know
what other topics you'd like our
scholars to cover in 60 seconds,
and be sure to like and subscribe for
more research and videos from AEI.